so what I'm about to show you is
something that the textbook doesn't deal
with actually for a few exercises which
to me seems a bit strange because this
is kind of a basic fact in the in the
topic of parametric's like what does it
mean
this parameter that we've introduced and
you can understand what it means now
there's nothing holding you back there's
no other kind of like foundation
knowledge that we need to establish you
have all of the pieces and all the tools
already and so even though you're not
going to do anything with this just yet
like you're not going to use this piece
of knowledge just yet I feel like it's
an important thing to establish early on
so I want to talk about the parameter so
we've got this guy here T we said that's
the parameter it's what sort of drives
both x and y x and y aren't connected to
each other so much as both of them are
connected to t through the parameter but
what is the parameter okay now to
establish that we actually need to use
the tools that we learn from calculus
and at all that you maybe wouldn't
expect to appear here which is the chain
rule now I'll come to the chain rule in
a second you wouldn't think that you
need the chain rule to do any calculus
or anything like this which is true the
train will come in an unexpected way so
to illustrate that unexpected way I want
you to notice just look at this line
just forget that there's this here for a
second
just look at that now what you've got is
X as a function of T X is a function of
the parameter right which means that we
can differentiate see now how would I
what would the right-hand side look like
when we're using this function notation
what does it look like when we
differentiate this we would normally
write that as f - t you know it f turns
into f - when you have a look at the
left side hand side though it looks a
little bit different for what you would
expect because the variables are
different right we're used to having Y
is a function of X but here I have X as
a function of T so my letters are all
jumbled up I'm not going to have dy/dx
out of this line for starters there's no
y and secondly this
is not a function of X is a function of
T so instead of dy and DX I'm actually
gonna have because you look at the
positions of the variables I'm gonna
have DX on DT that's what f dash T is in
this context okay
now I can work out what that is it's not
complicated this is a really easy
function remember even though you've got
a and T which are both pruning rules
they're different kinds of proteome
rules a is a constant it's it's a focal
length the parabola doesn't have like a
different length focal length here and a
different focal length there it's always
the same number I don't know what it is
in this contact which is why I'm
labeling it with a pruning rule but
that's a constant T on the other hand is
a variable that's the whole point of
using it here that as you change T you
change the position you are on the
parabola so when I differentiate this
that's why I'm doing it with respect to
T and I'm treating a like a premium rule
like like pi right that's not it's it's
a symbol what's a letter but it stands
for a number and so does a so when I go
ahead and differentiate a DX on DT this
is just a constant times T well when you
differentiate like this is a power rule
right your power one yeah it's just it's
just two a there's your derivative with
respect to T with respect to the
parameter when you have a look at the X
function okay so just felt that in the
back your bio we can do the same thing
here all right so whereas I got DX on DT
over here I'm going to get dy on DT from
this and you can see like following the
same pattern again a is just a constant
it's just a number so when I
differentiate here I get to a two now I
mentioned before that our we were going
to use the chain rule I didn't use the
chain rule in either of those spots just
now to differentiate either of these
functions because because they were so
simple the chain rule quiet but general
if you recall is called chain rule
because it takes a bunch of it takes a
bunch of derivatives and literally
change them together
what happens is out of this like we
introduce you as a substitution what
happens is you get the actual derivative
you're interested in by stringing
together these other derivatives okay
now there's no u substitution like here
in this situation
I've just got a different letter it's T
the parameter right you can see I what
to do reviews that have detained them
except for one little catch with the
chain rule you notice in order to make
this happen you've got to have do you on
the bottom and do you on the top as well
but I happen to have DT both on the
bottom so that's no problem
all I have to do is put DT on the top of
one of these derivatives now which one
makes the most sense well usually when I
end up with something I want dy on DX
because that's rise over run
that gives me gradient there's no reason
why I can't work out DX on DUI in fact
sometimes later on in this course we
will work out DX on DUI and you'll see
the reasons for that later but um run
over rise is not anything that means
anything to me at the moment so I'm just
going to go with rise over run that
means I do want dy on the top that this
one is fine
this derivatives time but this one I
want the DX on the bottom because I want
the the run on the bottom so therefore
I'm just going to take the reciprocal of
the left-hand side which means I should
take the reciprocal of the right-hand
side okay so far so good
so he comes the table part I'm going to
take these two derivatives which are
both in a good configuration now I'm
going to take these videos and I'm going
to chain them together so if I say dy on
DT times DT on DX they're just doing the
substitution there's the two eighty and
here is one on to a all right or the
left hand side as predicted like we have
normally with chain rule your DTS cancel
it's it's that's why we write these
derivatives a fraction two to clarify
that this can happen so you just get
dy/dx on the left hand side and on the
right hand side well it's tough
cancerous right like to a to a all go on
so all that leaves behind is T okay now
but put a big box around this what well
what does this mean okay
dy RDX well we introduced this like I
was talking about rise and run is over
before what does it mean do you want DX
is just a statement of grania but it's
the great new function because their
radiant changes all the time when you're
dealing with curves right
so therefore what is this what does this
equation say what the equation equation
is saying is the gradient at any point
is the parameter right the gradient is
the parameter